[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON RANDELL: Hey folks.
Welcome to Running a TV
Network in the Cloud, CBS All
Access on GCP.
So before we go into
the nitty-gritty,
I just want to address
a little background.
And so I think one of
the confusing things
is, when you think
about CBS, you generally
think about the
television network
that we are here to talk about.
But CBS Interactive is actually
quite a diverse company.
We, as the slide demonstrates,
were in the top 10
for traffic, nestled right
between Disney and Comcast.
But our various brands,
we have close to 40
different businesses
under our umbrella.
And it drives a tremendous
amount of traffic.
But today, what we're here
to talk about is television.
So before we get into
it, what I want to do
is just talk about,
at a high level,
what we're going to discuss.
We're going to start off
with where we came from.
And this includes the
TV industry itself,
what it's like for
us as a business
operating in the Cloud, some
of the challenges and lessons
that we faced from
that transition.
And finally, I want
to talk about probably
one of the biggest television
events that happens annually,
and that's the Super Bowl.
So I wanted to talk
about how we handled it,
what the traffic
looked like, and where
we go with those sort
of big tentpole events.
So where did we come from?
CBS has a rich history
in radio and television,
and we've done an impressive job
moving into the internet space.
CBS All Access is the first
direct-to-consumer broadcast
offering.
And we have a lot of
major television events
that we support on our platform.
The Super Bowl,
I just mentioned.
We also have the Grammys,
March Madness, that really,
if you saw this
last championship,
it was pretty exciting.
And we support our
own original content
as well on the platform.
So shows like "Star Trek
Discovery," and the "Twilight
Zone," as well as one
of our bigger offerings
coming back for the
third season, which
is "The Good Fight."
So one of the things
that we have to do
is that there are
expectations around broadcast.
And that is solving the always
on or always ready problem.
The expectation with any
media is that it's there 24/7,
it's available,
and it's on demand.
And what we're faced
with is a background
of really high product delivery.
We've got about 100 years of
innovation in the broadcast
space already.
And that's set the standard
for what the expectations are
for a company that
is doing broadcast,
whether it is through the
traditional broadcast media
or whether it is delivering
that content over the internet.
One of the things that we
face is that we're constantly
bombarded by rapid surges
in traffic, meaning that we
have to scale up very quickly.
I've mentioned some of
these tentpole events,
like the Grammys
or the Super Bowl,
and it can be a big challenge
to scale up so quickly.
Live sports broadcast that our
sports team has to deal with
and that we're often
dealing with ourselves.
As I mentioned, the March
Madness, the championship there
was one of the more exciting
events in just the last week.
So we get also call
outs for action.
In previous years, the
Academy of Country Music,
their top award, The
Entertainer of the Year,
was decided on CBS.com.
So that meant a tremendous
surge of activity
during the broadcast, where
one minute, millions of people
would be watching the show.
And then the next,
millions of people
are coming directly
to our website
in less than five minutes.
And then we have the natural
cadence of television.
So CBS marketing promotes
our premieres, finales,
special events.
And this all drive-- can drive
a tremendous amount of traffic
to our platform.
So where did we come from?
And now I talked about the
television broadcasting,
what I want to talk
about is traditionally
our delivery of our platform.
So we were in it--
our own data center.
And we had a service
oriented architecture,
and what we tried to
do is really abstract
each of the layers
of our platform,
that they could
communicate autonomously
and that they were stateless.
This allowed us to do
horizontal scaling very easily
at each level of our
platform, whether that's
our caching layer, our front-end
layer, or our back end.
So one of the things, though,
is that we had a single data
center.
We were not across
multiple data centers
and it was a single zone.
That comes with some advantages.
One of the big advantages
is resource predictability.
So we were running VM
there in the data center,
and we generally knew what
kind of capacity that we had
and what kind of traffic
we were going to expect.
Predictable change control--
in the data center,
we work with the systems
operations group, the network
engineering team, to schedule
any changes inside of the data
center.
If the load balancers needed to
be swapped out for a hardware
refresh, we knew when
that was happening,
and we knew we could act
accordingly with our platform.
The engineering
expertise-- as I mentioned,
inside the network group, inside
the systems operations group,
we were able to really
effectively leverage
that expertise outside of our
application engineering group.
And finally, a simple
cost forecasting.
Whether it was hardware
refreshes or models
based on traffic
growth, we knew what
to expect in the data
center every year
through capital expenditures.
So what were the
drivers for the Cloud?
Why did we move
from a model that
was fairly predictable,
that was easy to maintain,
and we had a lot
of expertise in?
So one of them was the
business expectations.
As our application and the
All Access product grew,
there was an expectation
for us to reach
larger and larger audiences.
And one of the things
is that we didn't
leave any money on the table
when it came to growth.
So we wanted to make sure
that as we were expanding,
we were capturing
the audience, and we
were delivering the product
that audience expected.
We wanted to maintain feature
parity with our competitors.
For good or bad, Netflix is
the standard in this space.
And we want to show that our
product was a premium product
and it can stand up to any of
the players in the marketplace.
So what were the
technical considerations?
I've already mentioned
that we had a data center.
And that's the single
point of failure.
So we had one pipe going in,
and that same pipe going out.
If that goes down, our entire
platform goes down also.
Fixed capacity-- we only had so
much space and virtualization
inside of a single--
inside of a single
data center can only
deliver so much capacity.
And at the time when we made the
decision to move to the Cloud,
we were reaching that capacity.
The other part of it is
that while the benefits
of predictability
are good, there
is a real long
procurement process
to get new hardware
swapped in and out.
Moving to the Cloud eliminates
a lot of those problems.
And finally, having
that slowed capacity,
single point of failure,
and that long procurement
process, where we're trying to
get updated hardware in place,
it does slow down the
application development
process.
Ideally, you want to
decouple infrastructure
from application development.
HANSON WONG: All right.
All right thank you, Jason.
So operating in the Cloud it--
for us, it was really
more about organization.
We had a massive cultural
changes within CBSi as a--
both a central
group, as well as a--
as well as within
our vertical BUs.
So we spent a lot
of time investing
in our teams to up-skill
them, introduce them
to new technologies, send them
to the right training programs.
For us, just taking a
step back, we were really
looking at, just a year
ago, and to some degree,
is still a little bit today, we
have a traditional operations
team.
You've got one side of
the team that's heavily
focused on systems engineering
and on the other side,
you got the application
team that's constantly
trying to rev and
build out new products,
meet whatever business demand--
whatever the business
demand might be.
So the problem was
it was also separated
by a wall of compliance.
You have one side that says,
hey, you don't get root access.
And you get the other side, says
come on give me root access,
I need to do this really quick.
My product owner wants me to
get this out the door really--
like, tomorrow.
So we had to kind of take a step
back when we went to the Cloud
and look at where the
engineering boundaries are
going to be.
We like Docker.
Docker was cool.
It gave engineers the ability
to start making some system
configuration changes, to some
degree, and application server
changes.
And not have to go
through an entire cycle
of putting in a ticket, waiting
for it to be scheduled giving--
getting somebody
to actually perform
that-- perform that task,
and come back and says, hey,
can you guys check it out?
Does it work?
That entire process
was extremely lengthy.
It slowed down our
ability to pivot.
We just weren't as
nimble as we could.
So going into the
Cloud, we're like OK,
let's take a step back and
let's understand where--
what are we going to do
to accelerate application
development, but also
maintain the compliance
requirements that we need?
So what we decided
to do was, OK,
within the of the
container, go wild, right?
And those of you that
have worked with--
worked with Docker knows that
it's not really root, right?
You get access to what
appears to be root,
it's pseudo-root, right?
So and on the flip side,
on the operation side,
we said, OK, let's start
putting some boundaries in place
because we don't want
application engineers to say,
hey, I need more
hardware, or more
CPU, more memory, because it
solves my immediate problem,
and it spins up all the costs.
And we need to put some
boundaries in place
to manage costs and risk.
So with our
traditional ops team,
we said, OK, so now
we don't want you--
you guys aren't system
engineers anymore.
You guys aren't
maintaining systems per se.
You guys have been building
a lot of code to build out
platforms for
inventory management,
or tools to augment our
ability to do deployments,
or things of that nature.
You guys are engineers,
you guys have
been engineers all
this time, you just
weren't branded as an engineer.
So we said, OK, why don't we
take a bit of a leap of faith,
and just start to
transition you guys
into becoming more like SREs.
SREs being people that are
comfortable and focused
on reliability, right?
So these guys are
the folks on our team
that was at one point,
system engineers, or SAs,
transitioning over,
building out code,
to say, OK, we need to focus
on forward reliability.
We need to focus
on observability.
OK, so we're going to
go deploy a platform
to start collecting metrics.
We need to start
looking at, how do
we make our infrastructure
more portable,
so that if we have
specific issues
we can move things around?
So our SRE teams have been--
it's really a transition
from traditional ops
into more of a software space.
So for us, we have both an--
both vertical SREs, meaning
within our BU, we have SREs,
and we also have a
centralized SRE team.
The centralized SRE
team kind of works in--
very closely with our
vertical SRE team.
They kind of act as
what Google calls--
and I want to steal
Mike's term here--
kind of act as CREs
to our SRE team.
So we have a perpetual
cadence of stuff
that we need to roll out, that
we've constantly trying to do.
We leverage a centralized
knowledge base
of highly skilled individuals
that help us build out
whatever we need
to build out know
because they're smart people.
Why did we choose managed GKE?
Or why did we choose GKE?
It really comes down to
priorities, like I said before.
We wanted to accelerate
application development.
And that was kind of
our number one goal.
And as Jason mentioned,
it was really,
how do we allow individuals
to focus on the application
and not so much
the infrastructure?
So we decided to
go with managed GKE
and focus on ramping up
our teams, number one.
Number two, redefine a
focus on reliability.
We wanted to make
sure that we started
adopting some of the process--
some the practices around,
hey, if you build something,
it functionally works
on your laptop, great.
You deploy it, it doesn't
work in production.
What happened?
So getting that instrumentation
in place, getting that--
getting that
instrumentation in place,
using those reliability
platforms that SRE teams are
going to be building
out, feeding that back
into our organization, our
engineering and product
organization to say,
hey, this is a priority.
You want this to work?
Fix this, right?
And often, like, when
you're revving feature sets,
you're not really paying
attention to reliability.
And I think reliability as an
after thought is how you're
going to get in trouble, right?
You don't want to
think about reliability
in the middle of the
Super Bowl, right?
Sorry-- cost management GKE.
We've been able to
leverage the Horizontal Pod
Autoscaler extensively.
So we don't get that much
traffic in the middle of night,
we ramp down our systems.
Throughout the day,
we have-- we do have
a lot of peaks and valleys.
But generally speaking,
we do you also
have a consistent
oscillating traffic pattern.
People wake up in the
morning, they watch the news,
they come online,
they go to work,
they don't watch TV anymore.
They come to lunch,
they might pop on,
and tune into their favorite
show, catch 15 minutes of that,
and so on and so forth.
And of course, for us, we
have multi-cloud ambitions.
We definitely believe that you
shouldn't put all your eggs
in one basket.
That's why we built
horizontally scalable platform.
That's why we have focus--
we focus on SOA.
We want to make sure that--
you know, if in an event
that we have a high profile
event, tentpole events, we do
have the ability to, say, hey,
this is not working
for whatever reason.
Let's go somewhere else.
Considerations--
it's easy to use.
I think most of you guys
that have experience
with GKE realized how easy--
how easy it is to pop it
in, run a few commands,
and next thing
you know, you have
your service up and running.
Frequent updates--
we want to make sure
that we leverage the
experts as much as we can.
Google has managed GKE
deployments forever.
So we want to make
sure that we're
getting as many updates
to the platform as we can
without us having
to do any work.
And of course, we have the
thorough support of the Google
engineering support team and as
well as our technical account
managers.
They're constantly pinging
us and saying, hey,
how you guys doing?
Do you have any problems?
Do you have any features
that you want us to evaluate?
Having a managed service allows
us to provide that feedback
and have leveraged the Google--
the massive resources that
Google has to do that work.
Challenges-- so I'm
the problems guy.
So the Cloud wasn't that easy.
So when we went from a data
center, as Jason mentioned,
it was a single zone, single
data center, single point
of failure, moving into
a multi-zone environment
definitely had its challenges.
So first, when we
were moving over,
we said, hey, we have this
monolithic application, what
can we do to tease this--
tease this apart,
identify pieces
that can independently scale?
We can independently
attach cost to it.
So we spent a lot of
time finding candidates
for transition.
SOA obviously, made
it a lot easier.
Since we're already
service oriented,
it made life a lot easier
for us to identify the pieces
that we could move over.
We didn't want to
lift and shift.
We obviously went
into containers,
and we integrated with as many
Cloud-managed products as it
fit within our architecture.
There's some things that
didn't, so we ended up
refactoring our code base,
roughly about 20% to 30%
of our code bases, to be--
to accommodate for some
of the integration points.
We want to make sure have had--
like we had this one
service that we forked off,
and it's really a
kind of isolated
feature of a digital
asset management system.
It resizes thumbnails.
Historically, the
source code was built
to work on a file system, NFS.
On the Cloud, yeah,
I can have NFS.
I wouldn't make people
very happy if I could--
I can have NFS, but it's
more appropriate to integrate
with object store.
So we ended up gutting
a lot of that code
and doing a direct
integration with object store
so that we can also
have the ability to--
the regional distribution
of our assets
and all that fancy stuff.
Monolithic to microservices,
straddling between the data
center and GCP.
We didn't do a single hop
jump to for our cutovers.
We actually end up teasing apart
roughly about 8 microservices
and slowly started moving
our products up into GCP.
Obviously, we had concerns
about dockerization.
We had concerns about,
like, is Kubernetes
going to work for us?
What happens when things fail?
Can we induce failure?
And how do we respond
to those failures?
We had questions
about all that stuff.
So what we decided--
so we started taking teasing
apart these microservices,
moving them up one at a time,
and just kind of building up--
building up our own skill set.
And of course, we had problems.
That's a bad look.
JASON RANDELL: [LAUGHS]
HANSON WONG: So for
us, it was really more
of a cutover problem.
So we'll go back to
the thumbnail resizer.
We tried to pre-cache
as much as we could.
So these are the
dynamic resizers.
So when you make a
request, it goes and says,
hey, I need this
asset at this size,
and it goes in and makes it.
And it caches that asset
and makes it available.
It doesn't resize
multiple times.
So we tried to pre-cache
as much as we can.
We loaded all of apps, we ran
through all the permutations.
Things were great.
The applications work.
We were able to validate that.
But we'd miscalculated
how many people
are hot linking our
assets on the internet.
So what happened was, as
soon as we flipped over--
that flipped over to DNS, we had
a tremendous amount of traffic
that just hit us.
So luckily, because we were
on Kubernetes, we saw--
we leveraged the
Cloud to allow us to--
well, if the Cloud has all
the resources in the world.
So we just scaled
out as big as we
could to absorb that
traffic for a week or two.
And then as the
assets were cached,
we started bringing
down the cluster.
But without having a
fixed infrastructure,
you wouldn't be able to do
something like that, right?
You wouldn't have all these
resources at your fingertips.
So the internal load balancer--
traffic distribution
is tuple based.
It does not account for
utilization on your back end.
So this one kind of
bit us a little bit.
We are accustomed to a stateless
SOA application, right?
So we expected
this load balancer
to just absorb our
traffic, round-robin
our traffic to our back
ends, and awesome, right?
Well, that didn't quite happen.
So because they are tuple
based, if you have connections--
if you have services that make
connections to these services,
and they're persistent
connections, they would linger.
And they would stick and be
fixed on to a specific node
until that connection dies.
But because we're trying
to optimize and not
make a bunch of
HTTP requests, we
decided to use
persistent connections,
and it just kind of
created a scenario
where it was leaning
on two of our services.
In this case, we
have four machines--
or four pods.
And over time, in the beginning,
when the system is restarted,
the connection pools
were hydrating.
They made a bunch
of connections.
Everything looked great.
20 minutes later, we get this.
So obviously, what
happened here was
that back-end services
with persistent connections
lacked the entropy necessary
for even distribution.
So we weren't able to get
even distribution with the ILB
as it stands today.
We did reach out to Google.
Google did come back to us and
say, it is a feature request,
so if you guys have
had this problem,
please reach out to your TAM.
We did, but because--
we can't live with this, we
obviously had to do something.
So we decided to think about,
what happens if we scale out?
If we scaled out, we would be
able to create more entropy--
right-- because the tuples
would have more entropy.
Therefore, the load would
be more distributed.
But over time, it
will eventually
lean against one
or two pods anyway.
So that wasn't
really a solution.
Application load
balancing-- so we said,
hey, maybe we can just
do this ourselves.
Forget using the ILB,
or allow the application
to make requests directly to
whichever back-end service.
Well, the issue here is
because we're in the Cloud now,
resource limitations is not
excuse I can have anymore.
We need to be able
to support autoscale.
When you do autoscale,
you have to figure out
a means for discovery for those
resources that come online
to become available.
We have to be able to inject
that into our application.
Do we really want
to reinvent that?
So lastly, we said, OK, maybe we
can roll our own load balancer.
We looked at
products like HAProxy
and a bunch of
solutions like that.
And we ended up using the
NGINX Ingress Controller.
And what this allowed us to
do-- now this still uses ILB.
But what happens is the NGINX--
so the leaning happens between
the ILB and the NGINX Ingress
Controller.
But within NGINX,
it's smart enough
to understand that,
hey, I need to make
equal distribution across
the nodes that I'm aware of.
And so the balancing
ultimately fixes itself, right?
So more problems, zonal
dependencies and KubeDNS.
So going into a data
center to multiple zones,
when you have a
relational database--
and maybe some of you guys
use MySQL here yourself--
you have a master and you
have bunch of replicas.
So you have to put the
master somewhere, right?
So it's either going to be,
in this case, A, B, or C.
And you have a
situation here now
that if your application
is running in zone C,
and you have a dependency on
zone A, if zone A goes away,
that's problematic, right?
So we need to kind of fix
some of those questions-- some
of those problems.
We looked at KubeDNS.
Like we said, OK,
KubeDNS is cool.
It understands when
services become available,
it understands where the
back end services are,
it goes and distributes that.
But KubeDNS has-- distributes
across all the zones.
So when that happens, that's
not really what I want.
I kind of want a scenario
that kind of looks like this.
This is a work in progress,
so I don't have a--
I can't sign off on
a full solution yet.
But we want to be in a position
where we are zone independent.
So if we're zone
independent, it means
that a request that goes
into zone A, stays in zone A,
gets processed in zone A. And
if that zone goes away, cool.
We'll just cordon off that
zone, drain everything
out of-- drain all our
back-end services at that zone,
and move on.
So in order for us to
be zone independent,
we have to move
onto HA databases,
High-Availability databases.
So we use Redis
pretty religiously.
So we started
thinking about, hey,
are we going to use
the cluster Redis?
Are we going to use
Redis backed on Sentinel?
Or do we just deploy a
bunch of different Redises
and just make the
application aware that they
need to call specific--
specific C names
for so that traffic
can stay within the same zone?
We looked at
cloud-managed products
like Spanner and Cloud SQL.
Unfortunately, they are
regional, so we didn't want--
or at least Cloud
SQL is regional.
And we didn't want to be
tied to a specific region.
We wanted to be able to be
in the US East and US West.
We are using Bigtable
for a feature set.
I'll come back to that.
But we ultimately, wanted
to be cloud neutral.
We wanted to make
sure that we selected
a database that allows
us to span multiple
regions, multiple clouds.
And so we are
evaluating CockroachDB.
To maintain traffic
within a single zone,
we are looking at
service meshes.
We haven't quite gotten to the
point where we can thoroughly
talk about this yet.
We're still evaluating whether
or not Istio or a other
competitive-- competing
product is the right product--
product approach.
But we are looking at
service meshes to do that.
And obviously, we have a
lot of decisions to make.
Lessons learned--
plan for failure.
All of our desire to be zone
independent, be cross-regional,
multi-cloud, is because
we want to make sure
that we have the capability
of failing out of a zone.
We have to make sure that
we have a DR strategy.
Really focus our teams
on setting up reliability
as a product.
You've got to build,
you've got to instrument,
you've got to evaluate, repeat.
Everybody's responsibility.
Focus teams on too much
instrumentation-- nah, no way.
Create a feedback loop.
I think this is one of the
bits about building out
a SRE culture.
You have to be in
a situation where
you have a blame-free culture
that allows instrumentation
to get surfaced, and not have
the person that's reporting
the issue be blamed
for X, Y, and Z.
And it has to be well absorbed
by the product engineering
organizations.
And it's a team effort.
That's the bit
about SLO/SLIs here.
And I'll let Jason talk
about the Super Bowl.
JASON RANDELL: Yeah, so Hanson
touched on a number of things.
And I think one of the
most important things to--
really, to emphasize
is the cultural shift
when you move from
systems operations groups
to an SRE mindset.
And one of the first
things that comes up
is collaboration with
Google and their SRE team.
I can't overstate
this enough, that one
of the benefits of working with
Google Cloud is that Google
really does want to become
partners with all of the teams
that come onboard
their platform.
And that means really
understanding our application,
really understanding
what our problems are,
and trying to help
solve those problems.
One of the things Hanson talked
about with the GKE component
is that there is a virtuous
feedback cycle with Google,
where we give them
feedback about our problems
with their products, they
go back to their product
and engineering
teams to really focus
on a lot of these problems,
and improve the services
for their customers.
So when we talk
about Super Bowl,
it's not just our team
getting ready for it,
it's Google also
getting ready for it.
So we spent months working
with the Google team getting
ready for this launch.
And what that meant is working
with our TAM, our Technical
Account Manager, working
with the support team
there at Google.
And we really gave them
an in-depth understanding
of our platform, how our service
oriented architecture worked,
and all of the
different platforms
that we were serving
this content on.
I'm going to pause for a
minute and talk about that,
because I think there's one key
differentiator in our product
in comparison to a lot of
our broadcast competitors
that are starting
to come online.
And that is that we have over
200 affiliate stations that
have their own local streams.
So we're delivering the local
CBS station regardless of where
you are in the United States.
That means that all of those
stations have to be up.
We have to have an
operations team,
and we have to
have a culture that
make sure that all
of our customers
are receiving the
product that they want.
So the Super Bowl
itself-- now I've
mentioned the 200
local affiliates.
So it's not just one stream
that we had to worry about.
It was 200-plus
separate streams.
And this includes
backup streams as well,
because one of the most
important considerations
here is mitigation
and disaster recovery.
On any event this size, with
your audience expectations,
you better be prepared
for something to go wrong.
So what we saw on the
day the Super Bowl
was greater than 17
times our normal traffic.
And you can see how
these requests spiked up
during the day of
the Super Bowl.
Now we had preplanned,
and as I mentioned,
one of our big challenges
around these tentpole events
is that we can have very rapid
request growth in extremely
short amount of time.
So always being
prepared for that
and not relying on autoscale
is probably a safe bet.
So before the event, we scaled
up 14 times our infrastructure.
And over the course
of the event,
I would say about 3x of
the additional scaling
was then managed
by the autoscaler.
But that gave us the
ability to really absorb
that initial request hit
that our systems took
without missing a
beat on delivery.
Now the good news here is
that calculating that scale
was pretty easy.
What we saw is that one core was
about 50 requests per second.
And we were able to do the
math and scale accordingly
so that we were able to deliver
at a really high-quality level.
Some of the
considerations that we
had to take in
account besides just
the massive number of
requests was scaling
our back-end database systems.
Hanson showed you a
little bit about some
of our current challenges.
Well, what we had to realize is
that as we scaled horizontally,
each of those cores taking up
50 requests per second, that we
had to scale those
connections to our database
in order to handle the
amount of additional load
that it was going--
it was going to receive.
So we had to consider the
upstream services, and just
the fact that more pods is
going to equal more connections
to those database systems.
So especially when you have
a single point of failure,
like we did with
our master, it's
a really important consideration
when you're thinking
about scaling up your systems.
So I'm going to give
this back to Hanson,
and he'll finish up with
some of the best practices.
HANSON WONG: All right.
So we've got some--
to kind of close off--
we have some best practices--
some best practices listed here.
Number one, test your
infrastructure, please,
because if you
don't test it, you
will never know, so especially
your critical services.
Work with your TAM.
Your TAMs are there to help you.
For us, we had a situation
where we say, hey,
we're going to get
all this traffic.
Do we have enough resources
allocated to our accounts
so that we can--
we can scale to that
point if we needed to?
So work with them to define what
you believe is the amount of--
or are the amount of
resources that you need.
They'll make sure it happens.
100% engage with
your CREs and SREs.
Treat them as if they were
part of your own team.
Do your architectural
reviews, make sure
that they understand how
each component actually
works, where your single
points of failure are, if any,
and where your most
critical components are.
Share your instrumentation.
The Google team has a
lot of instrumentation
behind the scenes that
can really augment
your perception on how things--
how things are actually
running from your metrics.
And runbooks, if you don't
have runbooks, create them.
You have to plan for failure.
So if you are going to get
yourself in a situation
where you may lose a master
database, have a runbook--
runbook entry in there that
says, hey, if this falls apart,
what do I do?
Who do I call?
Who do I scream at?
Product development
life-cycles--
we have to incorporate
reliability.
And it's going to be
a perpetual cycle.
You're not going to
able to get around that.
The whole point of planning
for failure, disaster recovery.
At the very least, have a plan.
For us, we have ambitions
of going multi-cloud.
Hopefully, that will help us
effectively have a disaster--
DR strategy.
But yeah, I think that's it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]